الكره لمين لماتيريس بيتي عرضيه بال
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
راخ هدف التعادل يا تاج يا تانج هدف
اوبروه كبيره يونسو
الشمسور الكوري في هذه الليله يحب ان يكون
عن ذكرى حلوه ليلى حلوه هدف حلوه مباراه
حلوه تاريخ احلام في سابا اجمل
ليله كبيره من قال انها ودنيه من قال انه
الدياب اياكم ان يكذبوا عليكم ليله التحدي
مليئه بالاثاره فيها بطاقه حمراء ولكن
الجزاء فيها سته اهداف ومتعه كبيره في
اجايك يسجل هدف يرد عليك يا راموس ويحتفل
مع سعود بهذا القلب الكبير الهدف لمصلحه
نجوم
موسم الريال نجوم النصر والهلال هدف
التعادل عن طريق جانكي منصور ليله كبيره
سوريه في استاد الملك فهد الدولي ليلى لا
تنسى اشبه بالحلم يا جماعه في هذا
الكرنبال العالمي الممتع الجميل للغايه
هنا في سعد الملك فهد الدولي